je vous donne aujourd'hui cette astuce
pour vous désintoxiquer de votre
smartphone bah ouais ces petites bêtes
là elles sont extraordinaires mais le
problème c'est qu'on s'en rend pas
compte qu'on est complètement intoxiqué
ça vient nous aspirer le cerveau est en
fait ça fait partie de la santé globale
le smartphone aujourd'hui prend trop de
place dans notre vie de tous les jours
c'est le cas pour moi et je m'en rends
compte et pourtant je suis tout le temps
dedans et je me dis non mais c'est pas
possible il faut que je lâche je suis
tout le temps en train de regarder je
suis alors attendre est ce qu'il ya un
truc nouveau ce qui s'est passé quelque
chose que j'ai toujours l'impression
d'avoir loupé quelque chose alors que
non non il faut se calmer il faut poser
ça il faut être en bonne santé et la
santé c'est aussi la santé mentale et le
smartphone nous prend proton nous aspire
trop le cerveau il faut qu'on arrive à
décrocher alors une fois qu'on en a fait
le constat qu'il est mon cas et bien
c'est bien on peut avancer j'ai donc
vous donner aujourd'hui cette astuce
pour me dire vous désintoxiquer de votre
smartphone et vous allez voir qu'après
ça si vous respectez si vous appliquer
scrupuleusement cette astuce ça devrait
aller mieux pas normalement je l'espère
mais on dit que le mois aux commandes
[Applaudissements]
la première astuce ses premiers points
c'est le plus important c'est de décider
de reprendre le contrôle il faut faire
le choix il faut pas se dire bon ben on
verra si ça marche il faut faire le
choix fait le choix de moi utiliser
votre smartphone fait le choix de mieux
l'utiliser les smartphones sont des
outils extraordinaires ils sont géniaux
ont un accès à l'information mondiale
c'est vraiment une vraie révolution
c'est pour ça que j'adore ça mais pour
autant voilà il faut y aller tout coule
comme toute addiction il faut commencer
par une décision celle de vouloir
reprendre le contrôle c'est vous qui
décidez à quel moment vous allez
l'utiliser et à quel moment vous n'allez
pas l'utiliser définissez les membres au
cas quel moment je veux dire utiliser
mon smartphone on peut se dire aller
avant une pause des jeux pendant une
pause dej je l'utilisais pendant dix
minutes ça peut être de l'actus a peut
être des mails ça peut être communiquée
avec des amis dix minutes vous fixé un
temps et vous le respecter et surtout il
ya des moments à proscrire par exemple
éviter avant d'aller vous coucher déjà
c'est pas très bon on peut y avoir de la
lumière bleue ça peut repousser
l'endormissement c'est pas le meilleur
moment de la journée éviter lorsque vous
êtes à table avec des amis éviter
lorsque vous êtes en famille on va trop
souvent des gens alors qu'ils sont
entourés viennent prendre leur
smartphone et viennent scrollé on sait
pas pourquoi il le faut donc éviter des
crochets définissez des moments vous
allez l'utiliser des moments vous
n'allez pas l'utiliser il faut que
lorsque vous prenez votre smartphone ce
soit un moment de plaisir et non pas un
moment d'addiction où on est aspiré
happé par smartphone et de la même
manière définissait des applications
vous allez venir utiliser pas tout et
n'importe quoi histoire d'y aller de
façon éclairée et de réellement faire
des choix et pour faire cela justement
et bonne année sur la 2e as tu sais bien
c'est commencer par classe et son
smartphone mois jusqu'à ya pas très
longtemps il ya quelques mois c'était un
foutoir absolue y avait rien de classe
et enfin deux trois trucs essentiels
mais pas le reste toujours trouvé toutes
mes applications lors qu'on soit sur ios
ou android ça peut rapidement être le
bazar à lorsque je vous conseille de
faire c'est de faire un peu comme j'ai
fait moi c'est à dire regroupés par
grandes familles ça c'est mon smartphone
alors je vous passe l'écran d'accueil on
arrive ici surtout le côté un peu
professionnel tu vas trouver youtube
facebook tout est classé donc là c'est
vraiment le côté plus pro ensuite
j'arrive dans le côté plus perso musique
divertissement je vais avoir netflix
voir tout ce qui va être netflix prime
vidéo mais canal tf1 molotov et
compagnie si un peu les différents
journaux que je pouvais lire tout au
long
la journée le cinéma la musique spotify
là je retrouvais sur des choses plus
personnelles la gestion de ma maison ma
liste de courses mais finances et
compagnie là c'est tout ce qui est lié
au déplacement donc tout ce qui va être
avions tout ce qui va être taxi tout ce
qui va être métro bus le train tous
trouvent ici et puis ensuite voir toutes
les autres applications qui sont
planqués juste là celle que je n'ai pas
forcément rajouter parce que je n'en ai
pas besoin dans mes différentes pages
sans être tranquille lorsque votre
smartphone est bien classé vous savez où
trouver la bonne information vous ne
passez pas des heures à venir chercher à
droite et à gauche donc on gagne du
temps et on évite de perdre du temps sur
son smartphone et on n'est pas happer
par une application qu'on verrait
apparaître à bétail à celle là je vais
regarder non vous décidez ce que vous
regardez à un instant t pour ça il faut
vraiment bien classés les choses
histoire d'être tranquille le troisième
point c'est de bien paramétrer son
smartphone et ça aussi c'est un point
qui est extrêmement important
aujourd'hui que vous soyez sur ios ou
sur android vous avez la possibilité de
venir paramétrer votre smartphone pourra
être tranquille et pour optimiser
l'usagé alors je vous remontre une fois
de plus dans mon smartphone ici c'est de
l'ios mais vous pouvez le faire sur
android de la même manière ça ne posera
absolument aucun problème vous venez ici
par exemple dans vos réglages et dans
vos réglages vous allez dans
concentration ici vous avez plusieurs
modes qui sont créées par défaut sur un
os mais vous pourrez avoir à peu près
l'équivalent sur android ne pas déranger
méditation repos temps pour soi travail
moi par exemple tous les soirs je passe
automatiquement en mode repos je passe
en mode repos à 23h jusqu'à 7 heures 25
alors à laquelle je viens me réveiller
pendant ce temps là j'ai aucune
application qui va venir s'afficher je
vais uniquement avoir des personnes qui
vont pouvoir un map les soins des
personnes que j'ai ajouté sur celles qui
sont dans mes favoris si vraiment il ya
quelque chose d'urgent mais sinon on
peut pas bien embêté peut pas être
embêté tu peux pas être happé peut pas
être interpellé par différentes
applications n'ya pas notification tout
est bloqué et ça c'est vachement bien
pour vous le faire de la même manière
par exemple pour le travail avoir des
applications uniquement professionnelle
soit les immeubles soit linkedin que
soit votre agenda pourquoi pas que l'on
peut définir pas mal de choses pareilles
pour de la méditation oui moi j'ai une
application petit bon bout qui va venir
à paraître uniquement et puis après je
vais avoir différents moments ne pas
déranger ou jeudi on bloque tout si j'ai
besoin d'être tranquille vraiment je ne
veux pas être embêté je peux venir créer
directement mes propres scénarios de
concentration si je le souhaite histoire
de nous réapproprier le temps et de ne
pas me faire embêter autre point qui est
important une fois vous avez bien
classés votre smartphone que vous avez
paramétrer les différents moments de la
journée sur lesquels vous ne voulez pas
être embêté par exemple c'est de la
productivité là c'est du temps pour
morlaàs et de la méditation on cloisonne
on verrouille comme ça on est pas tout
le temps arrêté par différentes
applications qui on est moins tenté et
bien ensuite venir regarder un peu ce
qui se passe faites un ptit reporting
dans votre temps d'écran que ce soit une
fois de plus sur un os ou sur android
orange tout le monde j'ai dans mon temps
d'écran et là je vais voir ce que je
viens consommer avec tout mon activité
alors aujourd'hui regardez je vois par
exemple vous déjà passé deux heures
alors j'ai fait de la santé forme
pendant 24 minutes des réseaux sociaux
pendant 40 minutes information et
lectures 28 minutes j'ai utilisé
beaucoup tik tok 31 minutes j'ai fait un
peu de sport pendant 24 minutes le monde
et réglages de l'insta g ça permet
vraiment de voir ce qui se passe en fait
un ce qui fonctionne ce qui fonctionne
pas je peux voir également les
notifications nous envoyer j'ai eu pas
mal de notification l'ag notification
tik tok peut-être que je peux venir les
enlever j'ai aussi des informations sur
mes notification et puis regardez je
peux naviguer de jour en jour voir un
peu ce qui se passe hier par exemple de
la même manière j'ai passé deux heures
trente huit sur mon smartphone beaucoup
de tik tok calendrier le monde instagram
des livres ou facebook bref je prends
conscience ici de mésusage de ce qui
marche de ce qui ne marche pas de ce que
je peux venir réduire est-ce que j'ai
besoin de passer autant de temps sur tik
tok je suis pas sûr donc à toutes ces
petites choses là qui permettent à près
de régler et de prendre conscience de ce
qui va et de ce qui ne va pas 5e astuces
cinquième point qui est extrêmement
important c'est de venir désactiver les
notifications on est tout le temps ap
votre téléphone et vibrac est ce qu'il
ya j'ai loupé quelque chose pour mon
cerveau c'est de l'information
importante j'ai l'impression d'avoir
tout le temps où quelque chose donc je
regarde en permanence alors vous venez
les désactiver sur votre smartphone mais
également sur votre monde sur votre
monde connecté ci sont liées ensemble
parce que c'est tout un problème lorsque
je me retrouve à vibrer du poignet ça
crée un stress et mon cerveau il dit
waouh qu'est ce qui se passe il faut que
j'aille voir alors j'ai désactivé mois
les notifications pour tout ce qui va
être réseaux sociaux je ne reçois pas
notification sur instagram sur twitter
sur facebook je garde uniquement les
notifications qui paraîtront être
importante pour mes sms appels du wat
sap sap est du messenger je conserve
l'actualité pour voir si un événement
important majeur et notamment au travers
du journal le monde auquel je suis
abonné comme ça je vous vois ce qui se
passe mais tout le reste j'ai supprimé
je ne veux pas voir pourquoi parce que
sinon je serais tout le temps polluer
alors après une déformation par rapport
à mon job je tout le pensons des réseaux
sociaux donc notification j'en aurai
détonne je ne veux pas mais vous par
rapport à votre vie par rapport à votre
métier par rapport à votre activité
supprimez les notifications qui ne sont
pas essentiels qui ne sont pas vitales
qui ne sont pas importantes pour ne pas
être pollué importuner parce que si vous
regardez faites le test à regarder dans
votre journée vous allez vous rendre
compte que vous êtes beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup pollué par les notifications et
non c'est bon ça suffit quoi je dire on
n'est pas esclave de son smartphone on
n'est pas là pour lui répondre dès qu'il
vous dire regarde je suis là regarde ce
que je souhaite c'est pour toi c'est
vachement bien non c'est moi qui décide
quand je vais aller regarder c'est pas
lui qui me dit à quel moment il faut que
je regarde et ça c'est important il faut
se rendre compte donc désactiver
vraiment les notifications qui ne sont
pas importants 6e astuces définissez
dépose alors on a effectivement défini
un programme on a classé son smartphone
on se rend compte de ce qui va on la
désactiver des notifications maintenant
il faut que vous de vous même vous
disiez je fais des pauses à quel moment
vous allez faire une pause mais par
exemple quand vous êtes en famille quand
vous êtes en couple quand vous êtes au
resto quand vous êtes à table quand vous
êtes je ne sais pas au fait des pauses
dit ok ce moment-là ce moment qui à moi
ce moment qui m'appartient ces
mouvements dans lequel mon smartphone ne
va pas existé j'en ai pas forcément
besoin j'en sais rien moi ça peut être
allez on pourrait se dire entre 18h et
19h je le prends je m'en occupe pas
c'est un temps pour moi définit ses sept
ans définissez votre planning de la
semaine est également le week-end quels
sont les temps qui sont pour vous
uniquement pour vous ça détend
privilégié et il faut faire des pauses
pour venir se détoxifier se
désintoxiquer croyez moi c'est vachement
important ça romano 7e point en septième
place comme un septième point c'est
l'éloignement physique parce que votre
smartphone si la cote est de vous on en
a toujours un oeil dessus alors vous le
prenez vous le mettez loin vous pouvez
mettre dans une autre pièce où elle m
sur ce même mois le mettre dans une
boîte pourquoi pas vous l'éloigner de
vous physiquement vraiment et c'est
super important quitte elle met en mode
avion histoire qu'on se dit ok je sais
que de toute façon même s'il à côté de
moi il un modèle je ne vais rien je ne
vais rien d'autre ok vous pouvez même
carrément l'éteindre et vous allez voir
que lorsque vous allez venir l'éteindre
le mettre ailleurs le mettre à distance
eh bien il ya une notion de bien-être
qui revient tout de suite on respire on
se sent moins sous la pression de se
dire à tout moment il faut que
j'apprenne à tout moment j'ai besoin de
regarder et je vous assure un peu
paraître tout bête on se dirait le bab
c'est n'importe quoi je vous assure
qu'on recense à moi lorsque mon
téléphone je le prends je lui mets très
loin loin de moi ou alors lorsque je les
temps et bien une sensation de bien-être
qui revient parce que c'est très
insidieux ce truc là mais on est tout le
temps a fait appeler par son smartphone
et si vous l'éloigner vous est peinard
d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré je voulais
vous le montrez une boîte au csa vegas
et fin podcast avec eux qui va être
bientôt diffuser ou qui peut d'ailleurs
peut-être déjà diffusés moment auquel
vous regardez ça la boîte elle s'appelle
pause bo zzz ya trois aides comme
monsieur gruia 3r chez eux ya trois
aides alors je vous montre pas ce truc
est vachement intéressant regardez c'est
sa pause points comme alors c'est pas du
tout spawn sommet sont plutôt qui est
vachement intéressant c'est un objet
physique dans lequel vous allez venir
ranger c'est une pochette en fait à
regarder vous mettez votre smartphone
dedans et ils ont une petite fermeture
connectés en easy qui se trouve juste
sur le côté ici et lorsque votre
smartphone et à l'intérieur il c'est
grâce à l'application dans votre
smartphone et communiquent ensemble il
sait qu'il est dedans il sait qu'ils les
iep est ici quelques mois là vous ne
venez pas l'utiliser alors pour autant
ça fait pas cage de faraday ça bloque
pas les notifications donc vous autour
des notifications dans votre téléphone
et si vous avez une monde vous aurez des
notifications non regardez aussi à
bloquer notification comme je voulais
dit juste avant mais ce truc là c'est
pas mal comme ça permet venir gérer se
rendre compte du moment où on décroche
effets des lois dites vous vous le
mettez dans cette boîte là alors il ya
un bénéfice pour vous mais il ya aussi
un bénéfice pour les enfants surtout
dans ce sens là que je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant et on en parle
justement dans le podcast et bien c'est
le fait de se dire on va éduquer ses
enfants à ne pas venir utiliser tout le
temps leur smartphone ils ont de la
gamification niveau monte niveau ils
vont gagner des points et vous pouvez
leur dire bah j'en sais rien si par
exemple tu n'as pas utiliser tant
d'heures par jour tel qu'on l'a défini
ensemble et bien au bout de tant de
jours tu vois un bouquin je sais pas
quoi des places pour le foot en face aux
classes est vachement intéressant
s'appelle pause et au zen zzz points
comme ce trouve ça un peu cher à 60
euros la petite pochette mais le service
rendu il est cool donc ça c'est bien et
puis voilà on a fait le tour de ses 7
astuces pour venir se désintoxiquer de
son smartphone alors après je pourrais
vous dire en plus devenir supprimer les
applications qui ne savent pas
réellement un grand chose vous vous en
rendrez compte la mesure où dans votre
tête vous êtes vraiment en train de vous
dire ok qu'est ce qu'ils déconnent
qu'est-ce qui fait d'utiliser l'argent
n'est pas réellement besoin et bien vous
verrez que les applications que vous
utilisez de façon des fois un peu
réflexes et qui ne servent à rien vous
venir les supprimer conserver réellement
ce qui vous happe ans qui vous apporte
du bonheur ce qui vous apporte une
source d'énergie positive mais tout ce
qui va être je dirais pollution on est
tout le temps happé par une app où on
passe des heures à la regarder avec le
système de scroll infinie ça c'est bien
mais c'est relou parce que notre cerveau
il en demande tout le temps on va tout
le temps cherché à venir activé le
réseau de récompenses dopaminergiques
donc on est là ok je scroll de scroll de
scroll quand on a un coup de mou qu'on
n'est pas bien ou qu'on a un coût de
morale en moins ce qui arrive souvent ça
peut arriver bien évidemment on n'est
pas toujours la grosse pêche tout au
long de la journée eh bien on va
chercher une source de plaisir immédiat
avec son smartphone alors c'est pas ça
qu'il faudrait faire donc prenez du
temps prendre du temps pour vous les
smartphones une fois de plus j'adore ce
sont des outils extraordinaires on accès
à plein de choses mais il faut qu'on le
fasse sciemment en ayant le contrôle et
non pas en subissant son smartphone
voilà c'est tout ce que j'avais à vous
dire petitement commentaire vous est ce
que vous pensez être addict à votre
smartphone est ce qu'il ya des choses
vous connaissez vous dit ben ouais c'est
vrai ça je le fais pas je devrais le
faire ce serait un sujet intéressant
vous me le marquer en comment table
parce que c'est intéressant de venir
partager de venir échanger tous là
dessus et puis si vous avez des astuces
des méthodes des choses que vous faites
pour venir vous détoxifier de votre
smartphone et bien marquer le en bas en
commentaires font ça cool c'est
vachement bien de pouvoir partager ses
bonnes astuces ensemble sur ce je vous
embrasse ce rendez vous une fois de plus
très bientôt pour continuer à parler
tech des bisous à bientôt
[Musique]